welcome to this video okay again I'm can
not pronouncing that what was this the
brain pick out something as the
translation okay we get a Ben Oni oh um
what was it that's them the snake benoni
got the snake benoni I only know that
this this business with Bishop g5 is
quite a decent setup I shred may I
should have played that play down a for
him but anyway okay hmm what this is a
day already wants to play before maybe
before and take on be too that's really
greedy yeah but maybe thats thats it's
okay i mean i won't play rupee 10 stuff
like that so if he wants to play before
I all the power to him that same okay
now he goes g6 okay I'm just going to
ignore this idea okay i can't go to a 4
actually that it's not nothing that's
not a completely terrible idea Oh
interesting I can play a for now and
after you captures I get an even if all
right okay
let's see it looks ma looks shaky f this
F 43 set up but if I get in efore and I
don't see how he prevented or Queenie
eight parents are Queenie ADA stupid I
should have seen that move Queenie 18
okay I think we need was was a problem
that that was I was Elysium check this
just looks excellent for white to be
honest Oh King King King to h1 hmm both
good but if I keep the bishop here on h4
he cannot move the d7 night ever because
of the caption so interesting
interesting question Bishop f3 for the
key for the cover yeah that's good hmm I
would love to get this night to deform
it hmm that seems very unlikely to be
possible okay I don't know a4 or not I
should try to improve this night not f1e
three years kind of thing
okay okay so he just moves this away hmm
does he want to play g5 that's that
super beginning so Wow Kim this was the
idea not on d3j I don't know Bishop I
can play Bishop f2 of course but yeah
okay let's do that just make sure that a
knight doesn't come down it's actually
really debatable if this was a good
decision or not I was thinking that
getting the night my night activist is a
compensation but maybe that's it was
wrong 94 he actually has before maybe
then I think I've misplayed that I think
I miss played that the position was much
better than it is at the moment what is
this e5 know the diagonal here is
sensitive if five
you can even take on 25 with in mind
ah come on the time what am I doing here
yeah
yeah kind of still sad that that I
screwed it up so badly and this was was
really really good for wine I mean like
really good and now I don't know what
this is but it's definitely not a
winning position or something like that
mmm I was actually thinking take stakes
gt5 let's get soakin not have tools and
time morning yeah it's okay d 59 f 2 mu
takes takes takes takes on f 2 p-8
Bishop c4 and I'm let's got the C porn
yeah he's got them he's got the bloody
see porn
now he's got rook c4r come on what in
what an idiotic game white resigns that
was really bad wha oh man i'm not quite
sure if this is so so clear but but this
is this position is really bad for black
is with without the two bishops yeah and
i have a big centers ah now I completely
screwed that one up okay he has this
night see 5d3 counterplay and I really
played a bad name maybe starting from
here on I don't know Joe I wanted to
activate the noid
yeah maybe I and I really have to
tolerate that the night is coming there
mm-hmm Jeff it's definitely not easy I
mean this is this was probably probably
bad I'm not worse or something like that
but it really doesn't it really doesn't
punish punish blacks plane maybe queen d
voice better awesome was something like
that I was thinking he just goes back
and I'm still having this issue with
nighttime night to d3 maybe I just have
to ignore that and it's possible that
Venus is not exactly bad on d4 I mean 93
this is probably pretty good for wide is
it is a complicated position it is very
good for white but it's not it's not a
not very a very self apparent or
anything yeah the comp says what does
the comp give like it gives me just 0.5
so it's not computer why it's not not
that high this evaluation I don't really
know why but I mean to bishops big
Center terrible bishop terrible night
okay I totally know why this should be
shouldn't be complete rubbish for black
but okay that's probably then probably
technical liabilities or something and
then the white position are the same I
just like it for wine ok and now
probably add should go to g3 I have to
just take off course hmm and it was
definitely better okay I went back 92
for Queen deform yeah it is still a nice
center and everything but Sharon knight
c6 was it was a bad idea really I was
hoping that the c6 porn is giving me is
giving me giving me hear some tricks but
there is really nothing going on it was
in fact that it was very bad of course
you have that that makes it very easy
for black but now I really I really
screwed that up it was a very nice
position but ok thanks for watching